>> NEW AND IMPORTANT REPORTING
ON THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S CASE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
CNN IS NOW LEARNING THIS:
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS HAD
ALREADY SERVED A GRAND JURY
SUBPOENA BACK IN JUNE AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
AT THAT MEETING THE FBI TOOK
AWAY SENSITIVE NATIONAL SECURITY
DOCUMENTS.
SO THEN WHY THE UNPRECEDENTED
SEARCH WARRANT THIS WEEK?
WELL, CNN IS TOLD THE FBI
DEVELOPED EVIDENCE IN PART
THROUGH AT LEAST ONE WITNESS
THAT THERE WERE STILL CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS STASHED AT THE WALL
PAM PALM BEACH RESORT.
WITH ME TO DIG DEEP ON THIS AND
SHARE THEIR REPORTING, CNN'S
EVAN PEREZ, CNN'S GABRY OR,
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR ELIE
HOENIG.
LET'S BRING THE IMPORTANT
REPORTING TO LIGHT.
THE SEARCH WARRANT, EVERYONE
SAID WHY WOULD YOU DO SOMETHING
UNPRECEDENTED?
THEY SERVED THE SUBPOENA,
THOUGHT THEY GOT THE DOCUMENTS
AND REALIZED THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THEM ALL.
>> WHAT THIS TELLS US IS THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
LAWYERS AND THE PROSECUTORS
TURNED CONFRONTATIONAL MUCH
EARLIER THAN WE REALLY REALIZED
HERE WE KNOW BEFORE THIS MEETING
IN JUNE THERE WAS A GRAND JURY
SUBPOENA THAT LED TO THE JUNE
MEETING AT WHICH POINT
PROSECUTORS AND INVESTIGATORS
WERE ABLE TO LEAVE MAR-A-LAGO
WITH CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
DOCUMENTS BEING HELD THERE.
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT, WE KNOW THAT
THERE WAS ANOTHER SUBPOENA THAT
WAS SERVED TO GET SURVEILLANCE
TAPES FROM MAR-A-LAGO, A
SEPARATE MATTER.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT AT LEAST PART
OF THE REASON WHY THINGS TURNED
OUT THE WAY THEY DID WAS THAT
THE FBI DEVELOPED INFORMATION
FROM AT LEAST ONE WITNESS, IN
ADDITION TO OTHER EVIDENCE, THAT
LED THEM TO BELIEVE THAT THERE
WAS ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTS STILL
BEING STORED AT MAR-A-LAGO IN
ADDITION TO THE 15 BOXES THAT
HAD BEEN TAKEN AWAY EARLIER THIS
YEAR, RETRIEVED AS PART OF THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES' EFFORT TO GET
THESE DOCUMENTS BACK.
THESE ARE PROPERTY OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND HAD NO BUSINESS
BEING AT MAR-A-LAGO ACCORDING TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
AGAIN, IT GIVES US A SENSE THAT
THINGS STARTED FALLING APART
BETWEEN THE TWO SIDES MUCH
EARLIER.
>> SO A SUBPOENA IN JUNE, A
SEARCH WARRANT IN AUGUST.
AT LEAST ONE WITNESS INSIDE.
THIS HAS TO, NUMBER ONE, RATTLE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THAT
SOMEBODY INSIDE IS TALKING.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION WITH TRUMP
STAFFERS, OTHERS AT MAR-A-LAGO?
>> WELL, LET ME FILL IN WHAT WAS
HAPPENING FROM JANUARY WHEN
THOSE 15 BOXES WERE PICKED UP --
WHEN ARCHIVES OFFICIALS SENT
FOLKS TO PICK UP THOSE BOXES TO
THAT JUNE MEETING WITH TRUMP AND
HIS ATTORNEYS.
WHAT WE KNOW, WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
IS THERE WERE MULTIPLE AIDES TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT ON STAFF AT
MAR-A-LAGO OR WHO WERE INVOLVED
IN TRANSFERRING THESE BOXES OF
DOCUMENTS AT THE END OF TRUMP'S
PRESIDENCY TO MAR-A-LAGO WHICH
IS NOW HIS PRIMARY RESIDENCE,
WHO HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWED BY
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT WAS SAID IN
THOSE INTERVIEWS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TYPES OF
QUESTIONS WERE ASKED OR WHAT
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS WERE
TRYING TO LEARN WHEN THEY SPOKE
TO THESE STAFF MEMBERS FOR
DONALD TRUMP, BUT WE DO KNOW
THOSE INTERVIEWS HAPPENED.
THIS, OF COURSE, SPEAKS TO THE
FACT THAT FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS
WERE LOOKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
WAS AT MAR-A-LAGO, WHAT WAS IN
THOSE BOXES AND HOW FAMILIAR
THESE AIDES MAY HAVE BEEN WITH
THE SECURITY PROTOCOL AROUND
THOSE BOXES AND THE INFORMATION
ITSELF.
>> SO DO WE KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION OF EXACTLY WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT IN THE SENSE THAT,
TOOK SOME DOCUMENTS IN JUNE.
THE FBI CAME TO BELIEVE IT HAD
BEEN LIED TO OR WERE MISLED.
THEN YOU TAKE THE DRAMATIC STEP
FOR A SEARCH WARRANT.
WAS THAT A STATEMENT SAYING
WE'RE GETTING EVERY LAST
DOCUMENT BACK OR WAS THAT A
STATEMENT THAT WE THINK THERE
WERE BIGGER CRIMES AT PLAY HERE?
>> IT'S TOTALLY POSSIBLE.
IT COULD BE EITHER.
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS WITH
THE NEW REPORTING, IT'S
BASICALLY SHOWING US IT DIDN'T
COME OUT OF NOWHERE WHEN THEY
DID THIS SEARCH.
WHEN YOU TALK TO LEGAL DEFENSE
EXPERTS, DEFENSE LAWYERS
ESPECIALLY, THEY DON'T EVER TALK
ABOUT WHAT CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED, THEY TALK ABOUT WHAT
LEGAL EXPOSURE SOMEONE MIGHT
HAVE.
WHAT ARE THE CONCERNS SOMEONE
MIGHT HAVE, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
WRITTEN ON THE SEARCH WARRANT AS
THE STATUTES THAT COULD BE
CRIMINALLY INVESTIGATED RIGHT
NOW.
IS IT JUST ABOUT MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED RECORDS OR ABOUT
OTHER THINGS, TOO?
IS IT A POSSIBILITY THAT THE FBI
COULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT A FALSE
STATEMENT OR BEING MISLED.
WE WERE HEARING EARLIER ABOUT
THERE WAS CONCERN OF BEING
MISLED.
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO SEE WHAT'S
WRITTEN DOWN THERE, WHAT'S SHOWN
TO THE COURT, WE REALLY JUST
DON'T KNOW THE FULL SCOPE OF
THIS, AND STILL AT THIS TIME THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ISN'T SAYING
ANYTHING.
THE PEOPLE WHO COULD SAY
SOMETHING IS THE TRUMP TEAM IF
THAT WAS WRITTEN IN THERE OR THE
COURT COULD BE ABLE TO RELEASE
THE DOCUMENTS HERE.
>> ELIE HOENIG, I'M BLESSED TO
HAVE GREAT GREAT REPORTERS AT
THE TABLE.
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR, PUT YOUR
PROSECUTOR HAT ON.
WHEN YOU HEAR THIS NEW
INFORMATION, WHAT DOES IT TELL
YOU?
>> JOHN, IT'S SUCH IMPORTANT
CONTEXT BECAUSE IT TELLS US FROM
DOJ'S PERSPECTIVE, THEY TRIED IT
THE EASY WAY FIRST.
WHEN THAT DIDN'T WORK, THEY WENT
TO THE HARD WAY.
HERE IS WHAT I MEAN.
THE FACT THERE WAS A SUBPOENA
FIRST IS CRUCIAL.
THAT'S THE EASY WAY.
A SUBPOENA IS JUST A SINGLE
PIECE OF PAPER THAT SAYS YOU ARE
HEREBY COMMANDED TO HAND OVER
THESE ITEMS.
APPARENTLY THERE WERE SOCK DOMTS
HANDED OVER AS A RESULT OF THE
SUBPOENA, BUT THEN DOJ
APPARENTLY REALIZED, WAIT A
SECOND, THEY HAVEN'T GIVEN US
EVERYTHING, AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THEY HAVEN'T GIVEN US ARE
NATIONAL SECURITY SENSITIVE.
THAT COULD EXPLAIN WHY DOJ THEN
SAID, OKAY, NOW WE HAVE TO DO IT
THE HARD WAY, NOW WE HAVE TO
SEND IN AGENTS, WE'RE GOING TO
GET A SEARCH WARRANT AND SEIZE
THOSE DOCUMENTS.
>> THIS RAISES GIANT
SENSITIVITIES FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED.
LET'S START WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IN "ROLLING STONE."
A SOURCE DESCRIBES IT, HE HAS
ASKED ME AND OTHERS, DO YOU
THINK OUR PHONES ARE TAPPED?
GIVEN THE SHEER VOLUME OF
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, I DON'T THINK
HE'S ASSUMING ANYTHING IS
OUTSIDE THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY.
YOU REPORT ON TRUMP WORLD ALL
THE TIME.
HOW RATTLED ARE THEY, IF THEY
THOUGHT THEY ANSWERED THE FBI'S
CONCERNS WHEN THE SUBPOENA WAS
SERVED AND THE FBI CAME BACK AND
SAID, NO, WE THINK YOU STILL
HAVE MORE, HOW RATTLED ARE THEY?
>> PUBLICLY THEY'RE SAYING
THEY'VE BEEN TOTALLY CAUGHT OFF
GUARD.
THEY CLAIM TO HAVE BEEN VERY
COOPERATIVE OVER THE COURSE OF
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS AND TRUMP
ATTORNEYS.
I WANT TO READ YOU PART OF WHAT
A TRUMP SPOKESPERSON GAVE ME
EARLIER TODAY.
HE SAID, MONDAY'S UNPRECEDENTED
RAID WAS ABSOLUTELY UNNECESSARY.
THIS CONTINUES TO BE PART OF THE
MOST EGREGIOUS ACTION OF
HOSPITALITY BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHOSE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WEAPONIZED
TO HARASS PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS
SUPPORTERS AND STAFF.
THAT'S HIS POSTURE.
PRIVATELY WE KNOW DONALD TRUMP
HAS ALREADY HAD CONVERSATIONS,
HE'S BEEN BRIEFED BY ATTORNEYS
ABOUT THE OTHER INVESTIGATIONS
HE'S FACING.
SO HE'S AWARE OF THE LEGAL
JEOPARDY THAT HE'S POTENTIALLY
IN.
I WOULD IMAGINE THIS WOULD ONLY
ADD TO THAT PARANOIA PLAYING OUT
BEHIND THE SCENES.
>> IN THE POLITICAL
CONVERSATION, TRUMP HAS THE
FLOOR TO HIMSELF AT THE MOMENT.
AND THEY'RE STOKING THE BASE,
SAYING THIS IS A WEAPONIZATION
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, WE
WERE COOPERATING.
YOU HAVE REPORTING THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS INSIDE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, SHOULD WE SAY MORE?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE
INSIDE THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD THEY SAY.
THEY TEND TO NOT SPEAK ABOUT ON
GOING INVESTIGATIONS.
THOSE ARE THE RULES.
YOU HAVE AN UNUSUAL SITUATION
HERE, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE, AGAIN,
THEY'RE TRYING TO PORTRAY
THEY'RE BEING COOPERATIVE.
WHAT WE ARE LEARNING IS THAT
THIS HAS NOT BEEN SO COOPERATIVE
FOR A LOT LONGER THAN WE
REALIZE.
IF YOU WANT TO CORRECT THE
RECORD, IF YOU ALSO WANT TO PUSH
BACK ON THE CLAIMS THAT TRUMP IS
MAKING THAT THE FBI PLANTED
EVIDENCE, AND REALLY THE THREATS
THAT ARE NOW COMING AS A RESULT
OF SOME OF THE STANCE THAT
REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS ARE
MAKING, I THINK THAT'S WHERE YOU
SEE PRESSURE COMING FROM INSIDE
SAYING THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SHOULD STAND UP AND EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT, AGAIN, NOT GIVING
AWAY THE WHOLE STORE, BUT
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE, TO REASSURE
THE PUBLIC THEY'RE DOING
EVERYTHING ACCORDING TO THE LAW.
>> GARLAND HAS MEMORIES, OF
COURSE.
HE WAS NOT THERE.
HE REMEMBERS WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT, JAMES COMEY
AND ALL OF THAT.
HOW MUCH DOES THAT FACTOR INTO,
IF WE'RE GOING TO SAY ANYTHING,
WE BETTER SAY IT ONCE AND NOT
CHANGE IT DOWN THE ROAD.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT, GET IT
RIGHT.
>> GARLAND ISN'T THE FBI
DIRECTOR.
CHRIS WRAY I'M SURE IS LOOKING
AT THE COMEY PAST THERE AND
MAKING SURE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE MAKING ANNOUNCEMENTS.
GARLAND, REMEMBER, IS A FORMER
FEDERAL JUDGE.
JUDGES DON'T SPEAK PUBLICLY WHEN
THEY'RE SITTING ON THE BENCH.
SOMETIMES THEY'LL WRITE A BOOK.
SOMETIMES THEY'LL GET A SPEECH
ABOUT A LEGALITY, BUT YOU JUST
DON'T SEE THEM COMING OUT UNLESS
THERE'S A VERY SPECIFIC TIME AND
PLACE FOR THEM TO DO SO IN THE
COURSE OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IT'S AN INDICTMENT.